[موسيقى]
طيب ترحبوا فيا كمان مره ولا شو
طيب
مين متذكر هذول القصص
يا سلام طيب انا اليوم جاي احكي لكم قصه
بنت كادت كل يوم تروح من روضتها على مدرسه
والدتها وهم طالعين كان في مكتبه بال
المدرسه هاي المكتبه كانت تشتري منها قصص
مجموعه قصصيه
تاني خلصت طبعا انتم بتعرفوا كنت بوقتها
بقرا كريستي جبران خليل جبران ابن المقفع
كليله ودمنه واكيد يعني نجيب محفوظ كان من
الثوابت عندي ومجله ماجد مين بتذكر مجله
ماجد يا سلام يعني انتم هيك حسستوني انا
مش حدا كبير ممتاز هلا مشيت الايام قصه
ورا قصه ورق قصه هاي البنت تربت على هاي
القصص وعلى هاي الكتب مين هالبنت هاي هي
انا انا كبرت وربيت على حب المعرفه حب
الكتاب حب القصه وانه انا انتقل لعوالم
ثانيه من خلال هاي القصص بعديها شو صار
اللي صار باختصار الكثير والكثير من
المراح ل قررت ادرس تخصص التسويق
طبعا لما اجيت ادرس التسويق في كتير ناس
حكى لي انه طب ليش بدك تدرسي التسويق حكيت
لهم انا شايفه حالي في هذا التخصص ممتاز
طبعا بجوز لما دخلت هذا التخصص كان في اخر
محاضره اللي انتو شايفينها بالكم بديش الف
وجهي كتير
المحاضره كانت ماده قضايا معاصره في
التسويق
حكيت عن موضوع العلامات التجاريه او
البراندينج وقتها بنهايه المحاضر رايحه
اشكر الدكتور وبالمناسبه هاي كانت اخر
محاضره الي بالجامعه اخر اشي كانت في شهر
سته ل2008 بس هلا
الدكتور بحكي لي والله شكلكم صرت تحسب
عمري فبعديها الدكتور بحكي لي دانا انت
اما ابوك معلم او امك معلمه ولكن في كل
الاحوال عندك اسلوب رائع في ايصال
المعلومه هالكلمه ضلت ترن ببالي ترن ببالي
بعديها بحكم اني انا كنت الاولى على
التخصص انعرض علي اكثر من شغله في قطاع
العمل تحديدا في البنوك وايضا حتى يتم
ايفادي لاكمال درجه الماجستير والدكتوراه
طبعا بخبره متواضعه في واحد من الشركات
الاتصالات قررت اني اتوجه مباشره
للاكاديميه ومن هون بلشت القصه رحت طبعا
بدي اختصركم كتير امور واوصل مباشره اني
رحت على
كملت من جامعه طيور ورجعت على الاردن طبعا
بالصوره راح تشوفوها هلا كان في نشاط
طلابي في كليه الاعمال هذا النشاط الطلابي
كان بيسالنا شو بتحب تعمل قبل ما تنتهي
حياتك
بصراحه هيك يعني انا كنت كاتبه حكي مرتب
زي ما انتم شايفين عندكم النصل الى حاله
مثاليه تجمع ما بين الطالب والمدرس
حكي كبير يعني انا حطيت حالي بموقف انه
دانا قررت تعمل هذا التغيير كويس وانا
بشوف حالي زي ما كل حدا فيكم لازم يشوف
انه بقدر يكون التغيير في هذا المجتمع بس
معلش خلينا هلا نشوف شغله مع بعض انا بدي
اسالكم سؤال
بس بدكم تسقفوا ما بدكم ترفعوا ايدكم اكم
حدا مدرس تحديدا مدرس مر في حياتكم
الجامعيه او المدرسيه اثر فيكم ايجابيا
[تصفيق]
وكم حدا بيعتقد انه في انفصال نوعا ما بين
الاشياء المعلومات اللي ممكن بناخذها في
المدارس والجامعات وبين سوق العمل
[تصفيق]
طيب معناته انا واياكم متفقين انه في
مشكله
مشكله شو اسبابها اولا احنا بنحكي عن
الطفره التكنولوجيه بكل والذكاء الاصطناعي
بكل تاكيد بكل تطبيقات الموجوده صح ولا لا
الشغله الثانيه متفقين انا واياكم انه في
فرق كبير وفجوه بين مخرجات التعلم
ومتطلبات سوق العمل والاهم من هذا كله
خلينا كمان شوي نكون صريحين محالنا ونحكي
كانه عم بصير فجوه ما بين المدرس والطالب
خاصه اذا كان في خلينا نحكي فجوات عمريه
كبيره متفقين معناته احنا اليوم اصبح لزام
علينا ان نحدث تغيير في المشهد
كيف نحدث هذا التغيير اذا بدكم فعليا في
كتير اطراف اذا بدكم موجودين بهذا الموضوع
وزارات مؤسسات هيئات حكوميه وخلافه ولكن
اليوم انا اخترت بس ثلاثه مين هم هذول
الثلاثه المدرس والطالب ونظام الدعم
والتوجيه او الاهل راح ابلش مباشره
بالمدرس
طيب المدرس اذا بنشوف اول شغله عنا اياها
اظهار الشغف والتحفيز ايضا اظهار الشغف
التحفيز طيب بدي اسالكم سؤال كم مره عمركم
سجلتوا دفعتها المصاري ورحتوا اول اسبوع
اسبوعين ثلاثه او هذا اذا وصلتوا الثالث
وبعدين تبرعتوا بالمصاري للجيم
اكم حدا فيكم اشترى قصه او كتاب او روايه
وحكى انا هلا ابدا رح اقرا روايه كامله
مئه بالمئه
ومين هون بدي احكي لكم شغله التدريس نفس
الاشي ليه لانه اليوم في مدرس بيجي بحكي
انا بدي ادرس ولكن هو طاقه شغف التدريس
فبفوت على القاعه بفتح الكتاب بعطي الماده
وبطلع وانا ما الي دخل فيكم عشان هيك
رسالتي وكلمتي لا زملائي المدرسين
والمدرسات اذا ما كان عندكم شغف ديروا
بالكم مهمه التعليم هي عباره عن 24 على
سبعه
للي بده يشتغل صح 24 على سبعه بلحظه من
اللحظات البنزين عنا بيخلص اذا ما كان في
شغف عندك او عندك فانت ما رح تقدر تكمل
المسيره فعشان هيك اللي بتشوف انه ما عنده
شغف فعل الاغلب هو في مهنه التعليم في
المكان الخاطئ والخاطئ جدا في الصوره اللي
بعدها بليز هاي الصوره تخيل في عدد الطلاب
موجودين هلا هون انا فخوره فيهم كلهم ليه
لانه معظمهم هلا انجزوا كتير بحياتهم وانا
متابعه طلبتي عن كتب ليش اربطها بالشغف
لانه المدرس الشغوف قادر عن ان ينقل الشغف
لطلاب الشغف على فكره ديروا بالكم معدي
شغف مش بس بالتدريس الشغف بالعمل والايمان
انه احنا قادرين نعمل ونغير بمجتمعاتنا
الثاني بعديه عنا مواكب تطور في المجال
المعرفي
اسمعوا في ناس دكاتره ومدرسين انا معي
شهاده الدكتوراه خلص يعطيني العافيه انا
سكرت العلم صح ولا لا خطا
كارثه اذا كان يعتقد الدكتور او المدرس
انه انا بدي اكتفي بشهاده الجامعيه او
شهادتي اللي انا وصلت فيها اخر درجات
العلم من هنا لازم المدرس او لازم الدكتور
في الجامعه او خلافه لازم دائما يتواكب
التطور
بالعمليه التعليميه
تمام لازم يواكل من خلال ايش من خلال
المؤتمرات من خلال الندوات من خلال ورش
العمل من خلال حتى شادات المهنيه وخلافه
بدي احكي لكم هون نقطه مهمه ايضا اليوم
احنا بنحكي عن قوه السوشيال ميديا صح ولا
لا ابسط اشي ممكن اي مدرس يعمله انه يتابع
الاشخاص قاده الفكر قاده الراي يتعلم منهم
ياخذ من افكارهم ويعمل قوله بهذا الموضوع
لا طلابه
للاشخاص اللي بيتابعوه من خلال التدريس
واخلافهم اضيف الى ذلك هونا يا سلام على
هالصورتين
يعني من 1960
فرقوا اشي ممتاز اجت الكورونا والناس كيفت
وفكروا على المدرسين كل الاحترام اكيد لكل
المدرسين منهم ولكن فكروا انه التقنيات
التعلم الحديثه هي الزوم ومايكروسوفت
ويعطينا العافيه وهذا اكبر غلط اليوم
التعليم وتوضيب تقنيات التعلم الحديثه اذا
بدكم تنطوي على الكثير والكثير من الامور
مثلا خليني اورجيكم الصوره اللي بعديها
بليز اذا بتطلعوا هنا انا فخوره بتجربه
الي بكليه الاعمال كانت مع ماده تعلم مدمج
من خلال ماده علاقات عامه في التسويق بهي
الماده طبعا كانت اول ماده تدرس في عام
2017 على مبدا التعلم المدمج شو كانت
فكرتها فكرتها انه الطالب هو يجب ان يكون
محور العمليه التدريسيه وليس دانا مش
المدرس الطالب انا شو كنت اعمل كنت اعطي
الطلاب الواجبات يعملوها ويرجعوا عندي
وبناء عليها انا ابني ابني بالمعلومات كان
عنا لافا اذا متذكرينها تمام
كانت مجرد ما احكيها الطالب لازم يقوم من
محله يقعد بمجموعات وبعديها بعطيهم واجب
بسيط وبناء على هذا الواجب البسيط بوخذوا
بونس او ريورد معينه فالفكره هون انه نفعل
التدريس في القاعه صفيه انا بحكي عن طلاب
جامعات نعم انا بحكي عن طلاب جامعات طرق
اخرى في عمليه التدريس اللي هو التعلم
القائم على المشاريع
شو التعلم القائم على المشاريع بالقاعه
الصفيه لا باخد طلابي زيارات ميدانيه على
مشاريع هذا مشروع
وهو معني بالسياحه الريفيه كنا نروح عندهم
زرنا لهلا تقريبا ثمان مرات رحنا معهم
زيارات وكان طلبتي يرجعوا ويطوروا اما
منتجات خدماتيه او سياحيه او حتى يطلعوا
بامور تطور المنتج نفسه بهذه الطريقه
طريقه اخرى في عنا انه الطلبه ممكن كمان
يعملوا مشاريع عاديه تطوير على سبيل
المثال تصوير فيديوهات او يعملوا بوستات
كانت لبعض الشركات التجاريه ومن خلالها
يحصلوا على فرص تدريب عفوا ايضا اذا
بتشوفوا عندكم هنا هدول طلابي بالماجستير
لعل الطلاب الماجستير عندي انجزوا ما
يقارب 31 خطه تسويقيه لمشاريه رياضيه او
صغيره وناشئه موجوده في الاردن وخارج
الاردن الفكره هاي ليش انا ما بدي طلاب
يعملوا على اشياء وهميه وبعدين اخذها
واصفها عندي بالمكتب الفكره انه انا بدي
طلابي يساعدوا المجتمع على قدر او قد ما
بقدروا على قد ما بقدروا والحمد لله في
اصداء ايجابيه الى حد كبير في هذا الموضوع
ايضا دايما بحكي طلابنا مش عارف قديش بخوف
هذا المنظر اللي قبالكم
لجان تحكيم
الله يعطيك العافيه بتفرق مع طلابي
فاتذكروا دائما انكم تحكوا لهم شكرا
وتقدروهم على اي عمل او اي مجهود بقوموا
فيه طيب هلا مش بس هيك على اللي بعمله اذا
بدكم بعطيكم وصف وظيفه للمدرسين فاذا
بنشوف اللي بعديها طبعا
صديقي اللزم اذا بدكم
انه قل لي وسوف انسى ارني ولعلني اتذكر
اشركني وسوف افهم فاليوم مبدا التعليم
لازم يتوجع اكثر لموضوع اشراك الطلبه تمام
طيب التواصل واستخدام لغه الحوار المناسبه
شو رايكم بقلب الحب هذا اللي موجود بالنص
حلو ولا مش حلو
ممتاز بدي احكي لكم شغله كتير مهمه
الكلمه الحلوه طالعه والكلمه السيئه طالعه
يا جماعه والمدرس اذا كان بيعتقد انه مجرد
خروجه خارج القاعه الصفيه انتهى دوره فهذا
مش سليم بعرف بجوز حدا يشوف انه فكرتي
فيها تمرد او تطرف نوعا ما يجي يحكي لك
انا كمان بدي اهتم بالطلاب صدقوني المدرس
اللي فاهم طلابه بقدر يستشعر فعليا لما
الطالب يكون مرتاح او مش مرتاح لما يكون
بده دعم او ما بده دعم بالتالي بس ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار اسلوبنا في الحديث والتعاطي
مع ابناءنا الطلبه تمام لا تيجي تحكي له
انت ما بتفهم
تعال احكي له وجهه نظرك مناسبه ولكن خلينا
نطلع على الموضوع من اطار اخر بصير ولا ما
بصير بعدين المدرس لو يحط حاله محل الطالب
بجوز وقتها هذا الطالب هلا بيعرف اكثر من
المدرس في عمره او في جيره اذا بنشوف بس
بليز البعديها اذا بتشوفوا انا بالعاده
بحاول اتواصل اكثر مع طلابى حتى بي خارج
الجامعه كان عندهم عروض مسرحيه نتواصل
خارجا باجتماعات او كلاب شايفين انا عندي
صفحه على الفيسبوك الفكره اليوم مش انا ما
بدي اجي احكي عن دانا انا بدي اجي احكي
لكم انه اليوم المدرس لازم يكسر الاطار
التقليدي وانه ما نضل لازم كنا زمان انه
لا انا مش لازم اعمل انا مش لازم
يكسر هذا الجمود حتى نقدر نعيد الشراره
للتعليم بطريقه او باخرى تمام طيب بس بدنا
نحكي عن المدرس
كم طالب موجود معنا اليوم
تمام واذا بسال كم هذا كان طالب الكل راح
يرفع ايده صح ولا لا طيب شو الواجبات
الموجوده على الطالب نفسه اولا لا تقبل
المعلومه كحقيقه مسلم بها المسلمات يا
جماعه
في عقل عنا اسمه العقل البعدي
يعني اذا دعنا بتيجي بتحكي لك على سبيل
المثال وماركتينج او التسويق هو عباره عن
4 عناصر بيجي شخص بتحداني بحكي لي لا ليش
بس اربعه عناصر واحنا عنا كتير عناصر
تانيه الفكره دائما انك تطلع عن تفكير
التقليدي وتحاول توصل لاماكن بعيده
الموضوع مش سهل
مش سهل بس انا اليوم بميز بين طالب قادر
فعلا على انه ينتقد المعلومه انا بعطيها
اياها بينطالب اخر عنده التفكير بس وين
دايمنشن عشان هيك حاولوا دائما تدربوا
عقلكم انه طب خليني اشوف وجه النظر الاخرى
خليني اشوف الراي الاخر وكل هاي الامور
قدر المستطاع تحديد الاهداف
كتير عن هذا الموضوع بس اختصرته بشغلات
بسيطه اولا انتم بعمركم تحديدا رسالتي
لطلاب او كلام لطلاب بجوز بتضلكم تطوروا
من اهدافكم من اهدافكم ولكن الفكره انكم
تحددوا اهدافكم باسرع وقت ممكن مش ضروري
يكون اكبر هدف عندك اياه ولكن حددوها ولكن
وين الفكره انه يكون في عنا خطه عمل
مناسبه للوصول اليها يعني شوفوا اليوم اذا
بدكم تناسوا لهم ماسك بتقدروا
بس ما بتقدروا انتم حاطين اجر على اجر وما
بتقدروا انتم قاعدين وبس بتنتقدوا الناس
اللي حواليكم بس متى بتقدر لما بكون في
عندك نقص بمهاراتك المعرفيه او مهاراتك
الشخصيه وانت بتشتغل عليها وبتحط خطه عمل
حتى تنجزها ومن هاي النقطه بدي احكي لكم
طلاب الجامعات والمدارس انه حاولوا
استغلوا وجودكم في الجامعات اكبر استغلال
ممكن او اكبر قدر ممكن بانشطه بندوات
بتطور وخلافه هذا امر مهم جدا برضه البحث
عن المرشد المناسب
بالوقت اللي بتحس انه خلص الدنيا سكرت
وجود مرشد ممكن يكون هو عباره عن شراره
الامل ممكن يكون هو الشخص اللي بساعدك على
وضع اهدافك ممكن هو الشخص اللي ممكن يحكي
لك كيف ممكن تحط خطه العمل الخاصه فيك
وبرضو المرشد يا جماعه مهم للدعم العاطفي
والدعم النفسي بطبيعه الحال تمام بعد
بالنسبه للمرشد المناسب بس نكتفي بالطالب
صراحه في دور على الاهل كم حدعونا اليوم
موجود
وعنده ابناء في المدارس في الروضات في
الجامعات ارفعوا ايدكم نشوفكم
هل انا راح اوجه حديثي للاهل ولكن الجميع
قادر ان يتعلم من هاي المعلومه واول شغله
واقعيه التطلعات اسمها بدي احكي لكم قصه
بنت
حولت تخصصها لتخصص ثاني ليش لانه اهلها
اجبروها على تخصص هل بنت هاي ضلت طول
الفصل وهي بس حالتها حاله ليش مش عارفه
كيف تخبر اهلها انه غيرت التخصص وقررت اخر
اشي انه تخبرهم يوم التخرج تخيلوا كميه
الضغط النفسي اللي بتعيشه هاي البنت انا
بس بدي احكي شغله للاهل انه لو سمحتوا ما
تحققوا احلامكم على حساب ابنائكم جبران
خليل جبران شو حكى حكى ابنائكم ليسوا ملكا
لكم وانما ملك الحياه بالتالي انتوا دوركم
انكم توجهوهم وترشدوهم ولكن اعطوهم
مساحتهم لاخذ الخيارات المناسب بالنسبه
لهم وبترجاكم لا تستصغروهم اليوم كل الناس
اللي قاعدين هنا عندهم قدرات كبيره انتم
عندكم المعرفه متاحه وبالتالي انتو عندكم
المعلومه ممكن باي لحظه اناقشكم باي شيء
وتقدروا تردوا علي وبالتالي مكنوهم
واسمعوا لهم وبناء على هاي النقطه اذا
نشوف اللي بعديها التواصل مستمر ودعم
النفسي بس شغله واحده اعطوهم مساحه امنه
للحوار
بستغرب مرات بيجي عندي طلاب بس اني ما
بسمعوني ودير بالكم تتراكم الامور تراكم
الاشياء النفسيه عندهم وللاسف بتطور
الموضوع لحالات اذى نفسي او ياذي عفوا
نفسهم جسدهم او يعملوا حالات يفكروا فيها
ارتكاب يعني خلينا نحكي نفسهم بشكل عام
تمام فالفكره هون انه لو سمحتوا الاهل هي
رساله جدا بسيطه خلوه اولادكم يعبروا عن
مشاعرهم قدر الامكان
ثلاث رسائل عشان ما اطول عليكم رساله
الاولى للمدرس انتم حراس المعرفه محفزوه
العقول مكن وطلباتكم ليوصلوا ليصلوا الى
ابعد مكان ممكن رسالتي للطلبه انتم تعيشون
في عالم مملوء بالكثير بالكثير من
المشتتات والمغريات
ركزوا على قدرتكم على وصولكم لاهدافكم
باقصى الطريق او بافضل طريق ممكن اما
للاهل فرسالتي ايضا بسيطه جدا حبوا
اولادكم ويسمعوا لهم واعطوهم مساحه امنه
للحوار
قبل ما انهي بدي اشارك معكم
صوره كتير عزيزه على قدي هاي الصوره
لوالدي تخرج من قسم المحاسبه في كليه
الاعمال في عام 1976 بنفس الكليه اللي هلا
انا اللي درست فيها واللي انا هلا حاليا
بدرس فيها طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين بخرج
المكفور له جلاله الملك الحسين بن طلال
هاي الصوره وبعد اربعين سنه اذا بتطلعوا
عليها بعد 40 سنه انا تخرجت من جامعه في
ورك من انجلاند لما طلبت الصوره وصلتني
بالبريد الالكتروني لما اطلعت عليها
انصدمت شوي حكيت اوف شو الشبه الموجود بين
الصورتين بليز
لما اطلعت ما قدرت الا اني اشوف بطريقه
وبكره بليز اللي بعدها لو سمحت قديش وجه
الشبه بين الصورتين وبعد 40 سنه
تخيلت للحظه انه الشخص اللي بيسلمني
الشهاده هو والدي وكانه بيحكي لي رساله
معينه انه دانا انا بشكرك على ايمانك
برساله اللي عندك اياها طبعا في فيديو
بسيط
شكرا
انتم بس تحاولوا تشوفوا الشبه الموجود بين
الصورتين بوقفه جلاله الملك حسين وقفت
اكيد مع بعض التشبيه ووقفت الوالده رحمه
الله وحتى الشخص الموجود يا جماعه في
المنتصف المرحوم له اكيد المرحوم عفوا عبد
السلام المجالي الدكتور عبد السلام
المجاني
طيب في النهايه لنؤمن اننا جميعا قادرون
على احداث تغيير في المشهد التعليمي ولكن
جميعا يجب ان نؤمن انه الا دور ونقدر نحدث
هذا التغيير من هون من صوره والدي انا بدي
اوجه له شكر واكيد لوالدتي الله يطول
بعمرها لاخوي واختي ولكل حدا كان داعمني
وداعم رسالتي في التعليم وبرضو اسمحولي
اليوم اوجه رساله شكر لطلاب الموجودين هلا
اللي تخرجوا هلا موجودين انه يجوا يدعموني
بيجي الكوري معي شكرا لكم واكيد بختم
بمقوله لخليل مطران بالعلم يدركوا اقصى
المجد من امام ولا رقيه بغير العلم للامم
شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]